hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and you know
if you're a longtime listener that I
tend to mix things up from week to week
the episodes are not really related to
each other for the most part but this
week's episode can in some sense be
thought of as a philosophical companion
piece to last week's episode last week
we had max tegmark talking about the
mathematical multiverse today we have
Ned Hall who's a philosopher in fact
chair of the philosophy department at
Harvard University who's done absolutely
important work on causality on the laws
of nature and also on the idea of
possible worlds the philosopher David
Lewis who was very well known in
philosophy circles although less
well-known to the general public
examined this idea of all possible
worlds and how they could be related to
each other not physically not sort of
causally but the different ways in which
they differed from each other and how
those ways entered into our analysis of
counterfactual conditions examining
possibilities that didn't actually come
true in our universe so I talked with
Ned about causation and the laws of
physics as I said and how we analyze
these ideas in the context of imagining
all the different possible universes out
there now Lewis thought to be all the
different possible universes were
actually real that they actually existed
that's very close to max tegmark Sai
diya of a mathematical universe where
every mathematical structure actually
exists but it's a little bit different I
think you can actually use the idea of
possible worlds in a way that doesn't
necessitate that you believe that
they're all real but whatever your
position on that is we're gonna get
there today this is a wonderful
conversation net is just a true genius
at taking esoteric philosophical ideas
and bringing them down to earth and
making them very understandable so let's
go
[Music]
at all thanks for being on the mindscape
podcast delighted you're a real honest
philosopher which I take it in some
sense is it unfair to think of what
philosophers do as taking sort of the
common sense questions we all have and
then taking them SuperDuper seriously
and digging into them I think that's
fair I think that's fair sometimes
questions will arise along the way that
you didn't anticipate and they don't
have any like clear common sense analog
so some of these questions you know
about so if we were talking about
foundations of quantum mechanics we
could ask questions like how do you get
a world of middle sized dry-goods that
seem to have a kind of relatively clear
geometrical arrangement in space out of
something as weird as a quantum
mechanical wave function yeah I wish the
physicists would take that question a
lot more seriously than I do but yeah
philosophers are definitely there but it
starts with looking at an object going
what's this that's right yeah so even
that question you could think goes back
to a question that together was like
very prominent in Aristotle you pick
something out in the world that's
familiar and you ask what is it and
there's a certain way of asking that
question where you haven't in mind a
kind of a certain kind of answer so if I
point to that book on the table and ask
what is it
it's you're not answering the question
appropriately if you say oh it's Ned's
copy of this report right it doesn't
capture the essence by somehow capturing
the essence of things
so there's many questions than we could
start with but I know the one that
you've written about quite a bit and
also I am personally interested in is
the idea of causation or causality cause
and effect what are your favorite word
their causation causality I'm ecumenical
okay I used to be for some reason I no
idea why I used to like bristle when
people said causality I don't know why
that's not the way I learned yeah okay
good so roughly speaking in our everyday
lives in the fault image we have of the
world the manifest image we are always
talking about causes in fact I got sick
because I had bad sushi or whatever and
therefore the philosophers like to
analyze this so what why is it even hard
what are the mysteries that pop up when
we try to ask what do you mean by
causation Oh
there's so their mysteries I think on a
number of different axes so one of them
we might get to later if we talk about
laws of nature but when we talk about
cause and effect that kind of talk goes
along with other kind of talk like talk
of the powers of things so for example
suppose you have a headache and you take
some ibuprofen and your headache goes
away and you say it went away because
you took the ibuprofen we would happily
add right ibuprofen has the power
capacity to cure headaches and that talk
of powers and capacities seems to
introduce a dimension to our sort of
picture of the world that's different
from the dimension were focusing on when
we simply give a kind of blow-by-blow
account of what happened where and when
it does seem to add something right
something that in some sense knits
things together and for Philosopher's
that's like no that's like the candle
sometimes you burn you know we want to
understand like what is that knitting
together and you'll find in the history
of philosophy like radically different
views about this some people think like
whoa right we just have to think of the
world is really having two aspects
there's the kind of aspect again we get
at when we simply report what happens
where and when when we filled out our
encyclopedia know of like the
occurrences that make up the world and
then there's the aspect we get at when
we say things like what causes what or
what has the power to do what or
ultimately if we kind of translate this
this into the language of modern physics
what are the fundamental laws that
govern what it happens so there there
are some people philosophers and Don
fosters like you think like really you
need a two-factor view of what reality
is like there's kind of the stuff that
happens and then there are the
necessities the payers yeah yes sirree
connections right as a hard-boiled
physicist but I will play the role today
the horse oil physicist since you're the
philosopher in the room I think I can
just get a along with just the stuff
doing things and the rest is commentary
in some sense is that one fair attitude
yeah the question is whether you think
that how you think about that commentary
so there is another kind of view
a long tradition which says there's a
kind of commentary on that stuff which
should be thought of as a kind of
conceptual grid we impose on the way we
think about the stuff that happens but
it's a kind of mistake to think that
that conception grid is latching on to
some structure it's out there right it
really is a little bit extra yeah yeah
yeah but okay but then there's another
point of view which says know that
there's a fundamental feature of the
world which are these powers like you
guys right and sometimes you can bring
out the difference by fairly cleanly by
thinking of you know imagining really
really simple scenarios so imagine a
scenario like this like a quote unquote
possible world that looks like this it's
got to Newtonian particles in it and
they sort of orbit around each other
because things are the initial
conditions are set up just right so the
overt around each other in perfect
circular motion thanks to the
gravitational attraction between them so
they've got mass no charge the only
force there is the gravitational force
between them and since we're Newtonian
it's not even gravitational waves so
that is forever right right right
and and it seems like I could describe
that scenario in a very different way I
could ask you to imagine a world in
which there are particles and each
particle just follows a very very simple
boring law that really permits no
interaction between them every particles
simply orbits in a circular motion we'll
have to imagine that there's something
that's moving relative to like absolute
space let's just let's just spot that so
that we can understand what it is to be
moving in a circular orbit without
reference to other material objects so
so here's this alternative way to
describe this there's one law it governs
every particle individually every
particle just moves for all time in a
circuit or urban and someone who thinks
that talk of miss necessary connections
or powers or causes or laws is a kind of
valuable useful and grid that we impose
on the phenomena will look at this and
say well these are two alternative ways
you might have of describing exactly the
same thing yeah so there really is no
factual difference between these two
possible worlds at all and of course
there's not really any Pratt
you'll mean served by describing things
one way or another because the world is
so simple the sensible world right right
like yeah there's no prospect of being
in that world and describing it there
are no people in there did write about
it right yeah right yeah because I
didn't say these are smart particles and
and someone who's on the other side will
say no no no there's all the difference
in the world as it were between these
two scenarios so one way they might try
to bring that out as they might they
might ask you to consider hypotheticals
pertaining to the worlds like they might
say well here's something that's true of
the Newtonian world if there were a
third particle somehow introduced the
motions going forward would no longer be
circular right which is almost certainly
right you'd have to set I mean you're
better at this than I am but you have to
set things up just right to still
preserve circular motion whereas in the
other world where there's there's just a
simple law that applies to all particles
separately if you introduced a third
particle then by stipulation it too
would move in a circular motion and so
so for people on this side of this
divide that we're talking about it will
simply be obvious that there has to be a
difference between these two worlds
because there's a difference in what
would be the case we're a certain thing
to happen and then you might you could
probably predict how this will go white
people on the other side will say well
look that conceptual grid that we're
talking about imposing on reality is
quite rich it includes talk of laws and
causes and talk of hypotheticals yeah
that's another aspect of the grid and so
all you're doing is drawing attention to
the fact that like the grid we impose
has this kind of rich conceptual
structure but you haven't yet convinced
me that that structure is answering to
anything that's really out there in the
world it's a little bit difficult even
to think too deeply at this level about
this very simple example simply because
it's so simple and we inevitably think
about those two particles as if they
were part of our much richer world and
that it sort of enables us in some sense
to ask these hypothetical questions
whereas the particles themselves could
never ask right right right right so
there's a different kind of example you
could think about
connects much more to our world as we
experience it although to motivate the
example I have to take sides on debates
and the foundations of quantum mechanics
know that in particular how we should
think about probability so so your as I
know you're very familiar with there are
approaches to the foundations of quantum
mechanics that say that the fundamental
dynamical laws are stochastic as it
worth write down the equations that
govern how things evolve those equations
have probabilities written right into
them and you can't explain away those
probabilities as a reflection of our
ignorance about initial conditions or
anything like that so let's just let's
just grant for the sake of argument that
let's imagine yeah or imagine that
that's the correct description of our
world like obviously we know quantum
mechanics has to be fixed but we imagine
any way of fixing it up is going to
preserve this irreducibly probabilistic
component so then you could ask well how
do you think about that probabilistic
component if you're on one side or the
other of this divide so for people who
think that the world has this extra
dimension many of them are just happy to
include a probabilistic dimension as
well and and that will that stance will
have certain like concrete ramifications
for example if I'm on that side of this
divide I think right there's just this
in addition to facts about what happens
where and when there are these facts
among other things about probabilities
I will think that while it's likely that
those probabilities are reflected in
observable frequencies there's no
guarantee of that yeah we could get
unlucky like we might be unlucky whereas
if I think that no talk of probabilities
is just another component of this
conceptual grid I have no particular
reason to grant that possibility it's
not even clear what it could mean for me
to say we could be unlucky in the sense
that disposability is nothing other than
the frequency yeah yeah yeah and you
have to be kind of sort of careful about
how you spell out that idea because
No we could ask embarrassing questions
like which frequencies determine the
probabilities I think those kinds of
questions ultimately can be answered but
but the the overall approach would be
one that said talk of probabilities is a
way to kind of encapsulate in a
mathematically elegant form a whole ton
of information about frequencies no or
it might be information that we don't
yet have so we could say our current
best guess about what those frequencies
will be I want to take a moment to talk
about peloton exercise bikes longtime
listeners know that I am NOT a mind body
duelist I think that the mind comes out
of the body and if you think that then
keeping your mind in good shape means
keeping your body in good shape and of
course if you're busy if you're trying
to do a lot of things that can be very
inconvenient and the peloton home bike
solves that problem when I visited the
showroom I was struck by the convenience
that this idea provides because
basically you can get on your bike and
do the equivalent of a gym class without
ever leaving your home there's a workout
for every different member of your
family no matter what your fitness level
and now there is a worry-free trial a
30-day home trial where you can try the
bike if you don't like it within 30 days
if you decide it's not for you you can
return the bike for a full refund
peloton will even come and pick it up at
no cost so this holiday give the gift of
peloton for a limited time get $100 off
accessories when you purchase the
peloton bike by going to one peloton
calm that's o n e PE l OT o n calm and
using the promo code mindscape at
checkout so I'm getting the impression
my plan was to start with causality and
go to other places but I'm getting the
impression there's so many other things
we need to think about before we really
do causality right that maybe we should
finish with causality and talk more
about things like the nature of the laws
of physics like when you talk about laws
you've introduced these concepts of
powers or propensity z' as a physicist I
hear philosophers talking about these
but they're not our language as
physicists so what are the different
ways that we have of thinking about what
you
by a law of nature a law of physics good
so there's one approach that squarely in
the conceptual grid camp that sees talk
of laws as earning its keep because of
the way that concept of law helps us
organize our view of the world right so
can I just rephrase that as there's a
bunch of things happening we perceive
patterns within it and this way of yeah
let me try to give an analogy that may
be kind of familiar and sort of easier
to get a handle on imagine you're a
mathematician and you do number theory
and what are you trying to do when you
do number theory well prove interesting
results about the numbers we have some
background view that certain results
would be interesting to prove in certain
other one it's not so interesting to
prove it's not clear where those
judgments come from but that's okay we
can just say like we tend to agree on
what's interesting and what's not like
pheremones theorem is interesting like
how many sevens are in the decimal
expansion of to the to the to the to the
to the to you know like it's not
interesting right and we also tend to
agree on which statements about
arithmetic are obvious may be obvious
enough that we would not feel ourselves
to be any more confident of them just
because we prove them from other
statements they're kind of starting
point obvious as it were and over time
we hit upon a small set of those obvious
statements that seem to do a very
effective job for us of organizing our
mathematical practice what do I mean by
organizing our mathematical practice
well when I claimed to have a proof of
something you can say Ned can you show
me how to get that proof from you know
our small set of no starting point
statements and and maybe we asked other
things of those statements as well we
want them to be powerful enough that we
think it's possible it's it's at least a
reasonable hypothesis working hypothesis
to think that we can use them to
establish or refute interesting it ok so
these statements are axioms yes I'm
I didn't want to beat the head so that
was like I was being sneaky about it
right that was the reveal this no no
that's fine you gave up it right just
the right moment like this is a view
about what it is for something to be an
axiom and and it's a view that's
anthropocentric in a certain way because
it's we who find these things obvious or
you know epistemic ly powerful powerful
with respect to their ability to know
establish or refute the claims we care
about
maybe there are other disorder we have
as well but it's it's not like out there
in the mathematical universe like if we
imagine like we're play tennis so we
think there's a universe of mathematical
truth it's not that son of some of them
somehow shine more brightly as like
being the fundamental truths yeah truth
your truth yeah yeah so so this is a
little quite capsule story about the
rationale for us humans who are
interested in number theory to single
out certain statements as axioms and and
it can be used to justify a choice of
axioms and we could all agree that in
certain senses its objective what the
axioms are what do I mean by that well I
mean we find ourselves agreeing on
what's a good choice things could have
turned out differently you know you
could imagine a race of creatures who
can think about numbers but there's vast
disparity between those creatures as to
which statements about the numbers they
find obvious right they're right but you
think two plus two is four is obvious
but maybe they can't like maybe I think
you can imagine those people but maybe
really every rational people would agree
yeah yeah and that which is an
interesting conjecture like maybe like
now we're getting into really deep
waters yeah maybe there's something
about the nature of rational thought
itself that kind of grounds or explains
why we find some obvious or some not and
and that would be very cool if someone
could establish that yeah but but even
if if that's not the case that doesn't
need to be a threat like we could still
say look it's enough for us to have an
agreed-upon way of organizing our view
of the world and I kind of like that as
an analogy for the way that this one
camp I might as well give them a label
call them humans after David Hume
because he was this Scottish philosopher
who famous
they deny that there are any real
necessary connections in the world so he
was on the side like there's a bunch of
stuff happening yeah and we impose some
way of talking about yeah yeah yeah yeah
and and that so that's one way to go and
and then a number of interesting
questions arise like what is the best
way to organize our view of the world
like the example of axioms is is maybe
overly simple in some respects because
it's a little too easy to spot the
interests of ours that are served by
singling out axioms whereas when it
comes to laws of nature there all sorts
of interests that might be served now
there's a lot of things that people are
they will call them the anti human side
would say in response but I think one
place to focus which is a place that
many of them will want to put pressure
is on a particular use that we put
concepts like the law of nature to which
is in explanations of phenomenon not
just predictions but explanations and
here you can see that the analogy with
mathematics is beginning to weaken and
maybe break down yeah is the more
science yeah right right cuz I think
there is such a thing as explanation in
mathematics presumably mathematicians
are in their audience we're gonna be
nodding vigorously here but it's not the
same as scientific explanation like in
scientific explanation it actually looks
like one thing that we do routinely in
giving scientific explanations is talk
about not just what happens but what
would have happened if things had been
different in certain ways so so here's a
nice example and you can correct me if
I've got the physics you learn on this
but my understanding of Newton is that
in the Principia when he argued for the
one over R squared
ya force law for gravity right the
argument was not that it was this law as
opposed to alternatives like maybe maybe
the force varies directly with our or
with no 1 over R cubed or something else
the argument was not well look 1 over R
squared gives you a lip tickle motion
it's true they it does and it's true
that other forces don't buy and this is
I have this on the authority of my spies
not it's not
I'm not read the Principia so so
audience go and check
at the time that Newton was writing the
empirical data was not precise enough to
distinguish an ellipse from the other
sorts of curves that would have been
given by other force laws well I'm
pretty sure that it was good enough to
distinguish between that and one over R
cubed yeah but I might be right but
there are other but I think you're right
there are things that would have done
just as good a job Imperium yeah
however the the one over R squared well
gives you a different prediction if
you've got other planets in the solar
system besides the earth which is that
the axis of the ellipse as the planet
goes around the Sun do you just focus on
the long axis of the ellipse that it
traces out that axis itself rotates over
time which it wouldn't if the other
planets weren't there no notice what I
just said there would be no precession
of these orbits I think that's the right
chair all right if there weren't other
planets no so I'll say it again like we
Newton puts us in a position to evaluate
a hypothetical if there had been no
other planets then this orbit would not
have processed and that actually looks
like it's an explanation of the
precession of the orbits and it looks
like an explanation that sites not just
facts about what does happen but facts
about what would have happened and how
do we how do we make sense of that well
thankfully according to these anti
humans we've got laws to appeal to and
those laws actually dictate not just
facts about what happens because they're
sort of more ontologically robust than
that they dictate facts about what would
have happened and they are what allow us
to kind of use these counterfactuals in
a rigorous and controlled fashion and we
need to use them because otherwise we
can't explain anything and I think
behind this is like a much much sort of
more fundamental so maybe maybe
fundamental in the sense of slightly
murky yeah thought which is that to
explain phenomena in the world it's not
enough simply to add to your description
of them you know you're kind of
blow-by-blow description of their
surroundings say but to explain why
something is the case you have to give
information about what it constrains it
to be that
and this so I think you're building up
to or maybe you've already achieved you
know the motivation of the anti human
viewpoint but as a human should I really
be bothered by any of this I mean I can
contemplate subjunctive situations
counterfactual I can ask like what would
have happened under other circumstances
so in other words as a human I think I
can look at the actual world distill
laws from it and then use those laws to
say what would have happened in other
circumstances so what what am i gaining
by this anti-union edition well if you
you can do that you might think that you
could if you wanted to describe those
hypothetical situations with reference
to any of a number of candidate laws as
long as those laws agree on the facts on
what actually happens they're all as far
as the world is concerned equally good
in the same way that different acts
imitations of arithmetic are equally
good as far as the mathematical truths
are concerned like you don't want to
include in an axiom a mathematical
falsehood but as long as you've got
truth math doesn't care the only
constraint on the choice in the case of
mathematics seems to be that we care
about using some rather than others
because it suits our purposes but it can
sound awkward to think that which
explanatory counterfactuals are true is
somehow relative to our purposes and
interests in marking out certain claims
as the laws rather than than others okay
I think I'm getting it actually so
remarkably in real time but but test me
on this so if I'm a true human and I
think that the so-called laws of nature
are just convenient encapsulations of
what actually happens in our actual
world that makes it harder to talk about
other possible worlds right I mean how
do I know which features of our world to
extend yet to those worlds yeah yeah and
you can stipulate that you can say for
my present purposes I'm going to
stipulate that the possible worlds I'm
going to consider are all worlds in
which the following statements are true
and now we sort of write down the things
that we're treating his laws yeah and if
you've got a stipulation like that then
you're okay
right the worry is that the anti-human
has with this approach is that the
stipulation seems like it's governed by
questions about what's useful to us
whereas what's explanatory what's
genuinely explanatory shouldn't be
governed by those questions I can give
you another example yeah I'm sort of
curious what you think about this but
it's another example that no we could
think see is like an intuition pump this
is a phrase philosophers like to use to
try and sort of you know tempt you over
to the dark side of anti humanism so
imagine that know some number of years
from now we're imagining kind of utopian
future where there's world harmony and
we've solved global warming and and we
know all human serve resources are now
devoted to doing fundamental physics
because we've all realized what a great
pastime that is so no war is just like
lots of fundamental physics everyone
gets a job yeah and we've reached the
point where we realize that in order to
test the the two sort of remaining
candidates for what the correct theory
of fundamental physics is like you know
we need to build this like super
collider that rings the equator no so
that we can achieve high enough energies
and so on and we built it and we've got
the test set up and and we realized that
the the experiment we're going to run is
going to achieve conditions that we can
possibly say have never been achieved in
the history of the cosmos and absent our
intervention on this case will never be
achieved unless there's some other
intelligence does this so these are
unique conditions and and now someone
sort of comes rushing in as we're about
to like fire up the experiments it's
like wait wait wait wait stop everything
I've just done some calculations we've
got these two theories a and B if Theory
a is correct the the test will go
beautifully and in fact will give us
results that will show us that theory is
correct but we haven't been careful
enough in working out the round
of theory be a theory B is correct this
test will set off a new Big Bang
this is uncomfortably close to arguments
people actually behead when we turned on
the Lord's head now if you're an
anti-human here's how you will think
about the the practical situation we
face you'll think there's just a fact of
the matter about which laws are correct
of course we could have gotten
everything wrong no we could have been
on the lucky and deceived and it's
really theory si si that's correct but
we've done our job well and so we have
entitlement to think that the true
fundamental laws are either A or B and
and and that's just the fact that's like
no e given independently of what happens
as long as what happens is consistent
with them it's a kind of
behind-the-scenes the rules of the game
are either the a rules of the B rules
and we simply don't know which are the
correct rules yet and so we can reason
if they are the B rules for all we know
they are the B rules and and so maybe we
want to be cautious and not run the
experiment because far we know we might
destroy the world
no it started us in it yeah if you're a
human and you think that that what laws
are simply something like highly useful
summaries of what happens it's really
hard to know how to think about this
because if we don't do the experiment
then the remember I said that the
experiment is going to achieve
conditions that are unique in the
history of the world if we don't run the
experiment then there will be no such
conditions to include in the summary
there's no fact to the right discern
irregularity right right so it looks
like you ought to say if we don't do the
experiment then it's it's simply
indeterminate whether the laws are the a
loss or the B loss but that's not the
way we would actually think about this
so a human could say well right our
thinking is infected by a kind of know
certain anti human elements and some
humans will actually point to history
here they'll say if you look at how
physics arose and say that
no 17th and 18th century it was against
a kind of theological background so
someone like Newton would have happily
said in writing down the laws I'm
literally seeing into the mind of God
like laws are God's commandments right
and if you had that view that's a very
anti-human view oh that's the most I
mean yeah yeah but the human might say
look we should have outgrown that so so
in offering this thought experiment
partly I'm offering it just because I
think it's fun to think about yeah you
get to do that as a philosopher but I
don't mean to be suggesting it's somehow
decisive in favor they anti-human but it
does it does show I think that there's a
kind of deep-seated component in the way
we think about the world that the anti
human is latching on to yeah isn't it
evidence against the anti he mean view
that there is no famous champion whose
name we can attach to this view like we
can for the humanity maybe that's right
I suppose an anti kami and I say well
that's just because like it's everywhere
he's my personally agrees I guess yeah
why are we calling it the human view
what what does David Hume have to say
about this well so famously Hume as you
mentioned before did deny that there are
any real necessities in nature and for
reasons I don't fully understand
he's now kind of the historical standard
bearer for that view I say that because
usually in philosophy when you find some
philosopher who's famous for advocating
some interesting idea you can find some
predecessor it has to stop somewhere
right
but humorous relatively late in the day
but but Humes own approach was kind of
interesting and and detailed and well
thought out enough to have a lasting
impact he added something to the mix
that we haven't really talked about
which is a kind of view that we humans
naturally tend to project kind of
features of our psychology out into the
world so so one example that might be
familiar or be kind of easy to grasp
this cup
we see the world is covered maybe it is
but maybe it isn't no maybe it's just
like atoms and no like electrons moving
around like reflecting light in a
certain way yeah I mean that's sorry
let's let's explain a little bit more
what it would mean for it not to be
colored I mean we we like you said we
experience color but you're saying not
to be colored in the sense that it's
just an illusion or it's just an
emergent phenomenon or what do you mean
the view I'm I'm imagining here which I
don't mean to be endorsing but just to
how it on the table is that it is an
illusion although unlike other illusions
like you know seeing a stick in water
that looks bent or something like that
a highly serviceable and useful Elijah
right okay so if you had to design a
human no a human being with like a
visual system in a way that would wear
that visual system would help the human
being survive and color sure yeah but
it's not really there that's a thought
no so we could use that as an example
it's very hard not to see the world as
genuinely colored but someone who thinks
it's illusion will be like well the way
our visual system works we're kind of
projecting when we take the world to be
colored we're kind of projecting
something that's properly understood as
a feature of the way we respond well
we're having this conversation what
mindset should we be and do we know that
there are things called you know
frequencies of light that correspond to
different colors or resource in a pre
that right so this view got going pre
that perspective but we're we're
advances in physics had gotten to the
point where the the the so-called
natural philosophers who took this view
about color were confident that that the
material world was just no material
objects in space yeah yeah and when you
bring in a more complex view of material
objects where they have charge and where
they're no they come in different
fundamental varieties so they're photons
and the electrical properties of matter
can make a difference to how that matter
interacts with photons it opens up space
for reintroducing colors into the world
right as real but in it but for purposes
of this thought experiment we were
honestly asking whether or not colors
are fundamental real
or just inventions okay good and so you
might think like that's an example of a
projection it actually occurs to me as
we're talking a much less controversial
one might be our judgments about like
what foods are disgusting yeah okay good
so I have I have a constant argument
with my family members about beets mmm
because no I'm very ecumenical when it
comes to food I like almost everything
except beets it's it's as if all my sort
of childhood food aversions coalesced
somewhere around age 18 into beets well
you know this might be exactly analogous
to color because it turns out that a lot
of people's visceral reaction against
certain foods can be traced to different
taste receptors in their tongues like
triste something like 20% of people
really can't stand raw tomatoes oh this
is something that is so so sorry for
them well yeah number one you feel sorry
for them but not only do they not enjoy
tomatoes but they get social approbation
because of it like they're somehow
flawed because they don't enjoy tomatoes
as much as they could but it's honestly
just physiological difference right
whereas fortunately for me beets are
enough of a fringe food that everybody
but you know I enjoy getting these
arguments where I will say look most
people just don't understand how
disgusting beets are but I know I
perceive the truth about these right
other people don't and of course it's a
joke right and it's kind of for our
purposes an illuminating joke because if
I were being serious I would be
committing what you might call a
projective error I would be taking my
reaction to beets and somehow projecting
it out into the beets as if what I'm
doing is simply passively picking up on
this feature disgusting this yeah it's
in the bees have right now yeah okay and
so sorry that is what hume accuses us of
doing yes with our talk of necessity
right in particular and here the
reaction is our own psychological habit
of expecting things so if you're walking
along and suppose you walk over a clear
glass
Payne and there's a 20-foot sort of gap
underneath it you will have a very
strong psychological reaction to that
yeah so that's just a vivid case but but
he thinks these reactions to the world
these expectations that we build up over
time or region and of course they are
normally when I walk along I don't think
about whether the ground will remain
stable under my feet
I'm just habituated in to automatically
expecting it wrong okay
good and so this is the connection to
the laws of physics is that these
situations are sort of our fault
they're not there in the world yeah yeah
yeah and and like the example of color
Hume thinks it's good for us that we
become habituated in this way he didn't
know about evolution but still so it
wasn't selected Darwinian Lee but but he
could at least say yeah there's clearly
a purpose being served by understanding
of their colors and and and patterns in
the world more broadly okay mindscape
listeners know that pretty litter is my
favorite brand of cat litter now
admittedly it became my favorite brand
when they sent me a free bag to try out
but the reasons are legitimate this
really is the best kitty litter that
Ariel and Caliban here have ever used
it's convenient they ship it to you so
it just shows up at your door it's
efficient it's a relatively small amount
that you need and one bag last one cat
for one month it's extremely good at
odor control there's not a lot of dust
pretty litter is manufactured with a
specialized D dusting process so it
keeps the area around your cat box
cleaner than average and best of all
pretty litter acts as a health indicator
it monitors your cat's health by
changing colors when it detects
potential underlying issues you will not
find that kind of innovation in
conventional litter so you can change to
a better kitty litter right now you can
make the switch like I did today by
going to pretty litter comm and using
promo code mindscape which gets you 20%
off your first order
that's pretty litter comm promo code
mindscape
does this connect to okay so well this
is this is definitely food for thought
for me because I tend to be a proud
human on most things but I think you
give me a good reason to wonder whether
or not I'm cheating and what I talk
about possible worlds and counterfactual
situations
this must be closely related to humans
famous problem of induction you know how
we go from seeing end things to assuming
that it's true for n plus one as well
yeah that's right and in the context of
which he was raising this point about
our Oh as he saw it or how our tendency
to project our expectations or habits of
expectations out onto the world as if
we're just passively picking up the
necessary connections that are out there
he was very concerned to try to show
that as he would put it induction this
kind of thing we do routinely or indeed
any kind of inference where we take some
limited data about the world and
extrapolate it could be towards the
future could be towards the past could
be towards the small scale to be toes
large scale any kind of extrapolation
like that was for Hume not rational for
Hume this point about projecting
expectations was part of a longer kind
of investigation in which he was trying
to argue I should say in a way that was
not received well by his contemporaries
that are are the kind of psychological
processes we go through when we
extrapolate are not really an instance
of reasoning that's almost sound okay
he's that crazy yeah to any scientist
you're saying that I'm not engaging in
reasoning and I take in data and spend
days or weeks or months analyzing it so
what is it an example of the kind of
induction that he has in mind that we we
are not reasoning about so a simple case
might be we could go back to something
like Galileo's experiments involving you
know freely following growing objects
Hume thinks that we shouldn't feel
guilty about the fact that after
conducting those experiments we all find
ourselves endorsing Galileo's
should say that objects fall we know
with a constant acceleration near the
source of the earth but he thinks that
we can't see that as a species of
reasoning and the the argument is clever
and frustrating and to try to
encapsulate it the the the key idea is
that that in extrapolating in a case
like that we seem to need to have as a
background assumption some kind of
statement to the effect that nature as a
whole behaves in a uniform manner so
before I go like to fill out the
argument let me give it a different
illustration is to imagine that Newton
had a had a kind of lesser-known brother
we'll call him I guess Newton was Isaac
become Isaac right
that's what philosophers do when they
want to introduce us but to the front
and ksham Isaac Newton published his own
version of the Principia complete with a
gravitational force law which had the
feature that it said that the force
between any two massive objects is a
constant times the product of their
masses divided by the square of the
distance between them until the year say
2020 and then it just drops to zero and
understandably nobody paid attention to
this you can see the trick here this is
a way of fashioning a force law that by
design gives you the same predictions
for any phenomena that we're presently
in a position to look at or test but
differs outside the range that we have
direct access also viable it's a good
time scientific theory yeah right but of
course this wouldn't be taken seriously
now as a kind of side note I will say
when I tend when I bring up this kind of
example in facio science classes they're
always a certain percentage of students
who want to say well we just have to
wait and see really they honestly yes
yeah yeah they think like well we don't
know
their daddy doesn't work that way but
but we can wait until 2020 and find out
okay
I mean arguably Karl Popper thought that
way Yeah right like yes list every
single posture when it can happen and
you chopping off one right one right
right and and I think human would have
been fairly impatient with this because
he would have correctly pointed out that
we need to make these inferences these
extrapolations in order to act in order
to know how to act so if you were kind
of designing a bait a probe to serve
sent to Mars you would design it under
the assumption that gravity is going to
continue to operate in the way it has
not all these hypotheses are equally
plausible right right right but you
would ask how so sorry so on the one
hand Hume is pointing out that it's a
bit of a unsupported extrapolation bond
the other hand he's saying but we got to
do it right right right so that there's
an aspect of humans view that's unusual
here which is that he thinks human
reason I'm gonna kind of go out on a
limb here because he hopefully there are
no human skulls in the audience but the
way I read Hume he thinks of human
reason as sort of like digestion no it's
something that serves us in a certain
way and it can serve us better or worse
but it's a mistake to overinflate it so
he's quite comfortable saying you can't
form a rational argument to extrapolate
one way rather than other however you
will find yourself inevitably
extrapolating one way rather than
another and certain ways of
extrapolating are better for you than
others
a typical scientist not philosophically
trained would just say well but look the
gravity is the same tomorrow as it is
today theory is just simpler yes
therefore I have greater credence in it
what's wrong with that yes yes so the
question that will now arise is how do
we know on what basis are we confident
that the world operates according to
simple principles and here's where Humes
argument becomes clever because he
observes that that very claim no the
world operates according to simple
principles or as he would put it in
nature's uniform that looks like an
empirical claim
and if you have the background attitude
that any empirical claim about the world
has to be substantiated by empirical
data but you also think that the very
process of substantiation in order for
that to get off the ground we need to
presuppose that nature operates
according to simple principles or is
uniform then it looks like you run in a
circle a little bit that's that's he was
famous presentation the argument for the
problem of induction yeah so but the
conclusion of it just to be very clear
because I think some people get this a
little bit wrong it's not that you can't
do induction it's not that you can't
just extrapolate it's that you're the
ground beneath you is shaky er than I
thought but you got to do it anyway
right right and the way I like to think
about it is you might have thought that
you could endorse with a clear
conscience this principle that any
empirical claim about the world should
only be believed if there's empirical
evidence to back it up but if Humes
right we have to abandon that we have to
say something like there's certain
empirical claims about the world that we
can't give up on pain of just not
knowing how to extrapolate at all and
arguably in some sense this line of
reasoning I must be getting this wrong
but somehow this line of reasoning seems
to be feeding into the argument you gave
for being anti human because in some
sense the we would have more
justification for doing these
extrapolations if we attributed the laws
of nature some extra property over and
above mere regular that's really
interesting that's a really interesting
suggestion and and there's a lot of
dispute within philosophy about that
very question so there are some people
in philosophy you can in recent decades
you could find this argument very
clearly presented in the work of say
David Armstrong who's a he's deceased
now but he was a very influential
Australian philosopher who argued that
unless we see was as having some genuine
power or force induction is irrational
it's not he would say it's non national
but he wouldn't say it was irrational
with all the negative connotations that
word has but these Foster's will say no
we need real necessities in nature
otherwise
if we take seriously the alternative we
should not expect anything about the
future no except beyond the planned
statement something will happen yeah
okay uh the the the tricky question here
is whether Humes problem is just gonna
rewrite so one way to bring this out is
against a kind of theological background
so it would be one thing if we could say
to ourselves look we have independent
reason to think that the cosmos was
created by a benevolent all-powerful
being and back in say Newton's day a lot
of people did think bad independent
reason for that believing that at any
rate it was probably not a good idea to
deny that in public but if you had that
view then you could say okay the laws of
nature just goes back to what you were
saying like the ultra the ultimate anti
human view is this kind of theistic view
you say they're these positive nature
they're genuine rules and furthermore we
should be confident that those rules are
intelligible to us that as where the
rules were built with us at least
somewhat in mind and that would give you
a positive argument for thinking that
the world is uniform or uniform enough
for us to discover its principles
because the alternative is that God has
this very kind of malicious or at least
mischievous attitudes levels and also
malicious yes right but it doesn't the
flipside work too I mean in the modern
perspective us being designed to
understand the rules seems less
plausible than well sorry the rules
being designed for us to understand them
seems less plausible than us being
designed to map onto the rules since we
obey the rules right we're part of this
world
yeah so discovering things about it is
maybe not completely wildly yeah yeah
yeah though there's a there's an
interesting question how far that kind
of perspective can take you if you have
the theistic perspective you might be
quite optimistic you might think we can
discover all the rules even the rules
that govern no phenomena an incredibly
small scale or at energy scales that are
incredibly large and so not the sort of
thing we would ever encounter whereas
there's a worry that if you think that
we are designed our cognitive equipment
is the sort of equipment
that will get us around well in the
world that's fine for caching
causal relations and regularities at our
scale yeah but you might you might you
might start to get uneasy like great why
should we think that the cognitive
equipment that evolutionist bequeathed
us with is gonna let us do you know
quantum gravity well as someone who
tries to pump for the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics I
see the resistance because it's so
different than whatever intuition is but
and I try to make the argument that at
some level some point in the history of
evolution we became you know tore
incomplete logic and then we can just
put aside our put aside our intuitions
entirely but not rely on them entirely
either right and so this brings us back
to Humes observation we said that's
correct that we seem to need to operate
in the empirical domain with some
background presumption that nature is
uniform yeah cuz that's not gonna fall
out just from logic no absolutely not
yeah okay and so if we asked like well
suppose we posit these anti human laws
but suppose just to continue at the
theological metaphor that we imagine
like their rules laid down by God but a
God whose intentions we have no idea
about at all like zero idea about plenty
right we'll think that they're really
tuned into God's intentions so this
would be a much more humble perspective
like yes there is a God who knows what
you want sight no idea whatsoever then
then Humes question looks like it's
gonna realize why would we expect those
rules to be what we would consider
simple no and it's actually I mean I've
been doing all the talking about it's
very curious what your take is on what
theoretical physicists think about
standards of simplicity well I was going
to mention it's been taken for granted
in most circles that you know beauty
simplicity elegance our guiding
principles when when looking for new
theories of nature it's come under a bit
of criticism lately
most most notably by Sabina Hassan
Felder who is a physicist who has been
saying it for a while but yeah I said
morrel ow
recently that we've been tricked by you
know looking too much or trusting too
much and elegance and simplicity and we
do have this looming empirical fact
about the world that we turned on the
Large Hadron Collider we had what I
thought and what most people thought
were very good reasons to think that we
would discover not only the Higgs boson
but a proliferation of new particles all
of those arguments were based on
considerations of elegance and
simplicity and they were clearly wrong
and so there's two ways to go either
elegance and simplicity aren't as
important as you thought or we got the
elegance and simplicity wrong right I
mean that's always a possibility so I
think it's still most people including
myself think that you know elegance and
solicita are extremely helpful of course
the data have the final say but when
you're extrapolating as you say into
realms that we haven't actually done the
empirical tests yet yeah of course you
put the highest probability on the
simplest thing going wrong right right
and that's a very interesting
observation because one of the things
that I think is really fascinating about
standards of elegance and simplicity is
that they don't wear their content on
their face no it's pretty clear what
sorts of things would count as inelegant
on any reasonable way of understanding
that like Mike Isaac Newton's a lot but
that may leave a fair amount of room
know within the things that could
reasonably be viewed as elegant and
simple presumably there's a fair amount
of room for maneuver well certainly
comparing Newtonian gravity and absolute
space-time to Einstein's general
relativity beauty is in the eye of the
beholder a little bit right into someone
who is not up on tensor calculus general
relativity can seem very far from
elegant right right right so there's
another aspect to this discussion which
is you may need to have a certain amount
of training it's real this you're biased
or not they need to have a certain
amount of training to appreciate
elegance in simplicity that's their I
think that many world is very elegant
and simple not everyone agrees yes but
well but you know to be fair to them the
connections we are forced to draw
between the underlying formalism and the
world of experience are not very elegant
and so if that's part of the theoretical
framework then right granted right it's
a mess yeah and that's a good point my
own instinct I think I have kind of
old-fashioned rationalist instincts I
would have been very good without my
owns instinct is to think that the
principles of elegance and simplicity
should be seen as good guides if you're
down at the level of fundamental physics
and then from then on up things get
Messier and Messier and when I come back
to this one we talked about causation
because that's part of what makes
causation such a vexed topic is that as
you scale up the kinds of relationships
you can cleanly track become fewer and
far between well yeah let's let's start
moving in that direction for the
argument in favor of taking anti
comunism seriously it relied on various
hypothetical counterfactual situations
right and this we toss around the phrase
possible worlds and probably Hume didn't
toss around that phrase or Newton but
it's become very popular in recent
decades in philosophy in his was David
Lewis your adviser he was my he was one
of my mentors and was not officially an
advisor but he's someone that I worked
very closely with so explain to the to
the audience why philosophers love to
talk about possible worlds oh okay
that's a complicated question there are
all sorts of different reasons let me
let me highlight a couple very different
reasons one reason is that it possible
worlds just seem like an interesting
topic in their own right how did they
become an interesting topic well by a
connection to something that we could
already recognize if we go back to your
original comments as part of our basic
way of thinking about the world that we
we seem to draw distinctions between
what could be the case and what has to
be the case and for a philosopher that's
just puzzling like how what is that
distinction yeah if we draw it all the
time without yeah yeah that's right and
over the course of the 20th century
probably starting somewhere in the 40s
I'm a little hazy on the history here it
came to seem that we could clarify that
question if we
talked not directly in terms of possibly
necessity just using those word words
but in terms of possible worlds where
the intuitive conception of what a
possible world is is it's a way that
reality as a whole could have been
another way to put it which is a little
more illuminating is a possible word is
something like a complete consistent
story about the world so this is a
footnote it's very different than the
many worlds of quantum mechanics yes
they're all just a pieces of the CS
world so the world to mean all of
reality that's right that's right that's
right so many worlds interpretations of
quantum mechanics would describe one
possible way for reality as a whole to
be and on that way of describing it
rowdies whole contains multiple cosmo
that's whatever the poro of cosmos is
yeah
whereas for philosophers who are talking
about possible worlds there's no
connection between possible worlds in
the way that there's a connection
between no different branches of the
multiverse so so far so good we have we
can say look here's a here's a kind of
convenient way to clarify the regiment
or talk of possibility and necessity
we'll talk about what is the case
according to a complete and consistent
description of reality as a whole and
what which includes just to make it
perfectly clear not only the purported
laws of that world individual events
that happen that's right like that's
right if I had not caused the street
that's right denotes a possible world
yeah yeah now why would you want to talk
this way there there are a number of
different motivations and I'm definitely
not going to do justice to them all some
of them come from analyzing language
like you want a kind of a systematic
analysis of logical connections between
statements about what could have been
the case and what is the case and what
must have been the case or you simply
want to have a way of clarifying what I
mean when I say something like this I
could have been taller than I am right
but so let's just pause over that
example we can all hear that there's an
ambiguity there yeah on one way of
hearing that
it's obviously false wouldn't be you if
you know yeah and another way of hearing
it it's no plausible and if you embrace
talk
world's you can clarify the difference
you can say on one way of hearing it I
am asserting that there's a possible
world according to which Ned as Ned is
in that world is taller than Ned as he
is in that world and there is no such
possible role you know in any world in
which I exist
I list halls I know another way of
understanding it I'm saying there's a
world in which Ned s he is in that world
as a height greater than Ned as he is in
the actual world yeah and so we see this
it just in microcosm here how talking
possible worlds can help clarify
distinctions that ordinary language can
kind of work yeah okay and I want to you
know mention the name David Lewis
because I think he's probably the
greatest ratio of importance to modern
philosophy versus public recognition
right like those people on this yeah
never heard of that anyway they forget
sorry and he took this you know he did a
lot of the spade work in making sense of
this notion of possible worlds and he
went so far as to say they're all real
in some sense right
yes moral realism that's right and it's
hard to overstate how dramatic this move
is so so far if you're hearing the way
I'm talking about possible words you
might think like alright that seems like
a useful device yeah Lewis wanted to say
it's not just a useful device he wanted
he didn't just want to say he did say
that that in order for us to use this
talk of possible worlds with a kind of
clean intellectual conscience we need to
answer the question a version of the
question that we started this podcast
with which is what are they and it's not
enough just to say their stories no
because Lewis would say okay stories in
what language exactly the are these
stories that are graspable are they
written in a language that could be
understood by a human a little awkwardly
if there's stories they can't just be
any stories because they have to be
consistent on the usual way of
understanding it
and they have to be complete in that the
story as it were answers any question we
might pose of it the whole long right
and and that notion of completeness is
actually related to consistency through
the back door because part of what we
mean by saying a story is complete is
that any addition to it would render it
inconsistent no it's so full and how
that says about the world that it
couldn't say anything more without
collapsing ending there's no answer to
every question might allow all right
right right right but just focus on this
demand of consistency Louis would want
to know well what do we mean by
consistent there and for him it was very
important to give an answer to that that
didn't just reintroduce notions of
possibility in necessity so there's a
move he's making here that that for
people who are coming at this from
outside philosophy is going to seem
strange and cards on the table rightly
so but but the move is to say it's not
enough to use this notion of possible
worlds to clarify our talk of
possibility necessity we need to use it
to analyze that talk into some other
terms so what do we mean by analyzing
talk into other terms
well it's helpful to draw on mathematics
here so in number theory we don't think
of the notion of a prime number is a
kind of primitive notion like we're you
know like it's like jazz like if you
have to ask what a fun number in an
aesthetic you've obviously never worked
with honor or something like that we
think we can define precisely what a
prime number is in other terms and in
philosophy and indeed in the sciences
and mathematics we very often face this
question when should we take some term
as needing to be defined
why don't we should think when should we
think they're said if we're going to use
this term with a good conscience we
really need a story about how to
understand it in other terms I for
example think or talk of causality is
like that I think we there's as a matter
of good intellectual hygiene we really
need to explain or talk of causation
cause-and-effect in some other terms to
fiendishly difficult to do that Lewis
thought we had to do that with our
notions of possibility in assess
and he thought he could do that if in a
two-step process so first step to say
that something is possible is to say
that there's a possible world in which
it's true okay okay the second step a
possible world is literally a concrete
chunk of reality as a whole how is it
related to the chunk that we were in it
bears no space-time relation to our
chunk at all it is in that sense a
completely separate chunk of reality now
notice something fast just happened
I said it's a chunk of reality that is
reality as a whole includes the actual
world and it includes other concrete
material chunks that are other possible
worlds but didn't I say before that a
possible world was a way that reality as
a whole could be yeah well you can't say
both of those those words are failing us
yes yeah yeah and so we were recognized
that and he said right when I say just
to sort of watch the basic idea in your
head that a possible world is away
reality as a whole could be I didn't
really mean reality as a whole I meant
our corner yeah okay so that's sort of
the whole package there parenthetically
max tegmark has reinvented and
reintroduced this idea from a
cosmological point in you saying that
every mathematical structure corresponds
to a real existing rate this it
corresponds to err is channeling max
that you'd say is yeah and so it's gonna
get us a feel but I'm gonna say it
anyway there's a measure problem in this
case yes Mike yes if all the possible
worlds exist one exists where gravity is
the inverse square law up until 2020
that's right and why can we therefore
say it probably is it so Lewis himself
didn't have a lot to say about the
problem of induction I think and and I
say this just from conversations I had
with him not from me no I've my
knowledge of what he's written
I brought a lot of what he's written
though I may have missed something I
think he thought it was just unavoidable
that we have to spot ourselves something
like a rational entitlement to believe
that the corner of reality that we're in
the actual world is simple and elegant
but so max would like to say so I think
he's actually improved that a little bit
he's saying like there is some measure
of simplicity in the sense of you know
algorithmic simplicity like the way the
shortest descriptions of the entire
universe get more weight somehow than
longer ones and I think that he's just
pulled that out of nothing but at least
it would help so it would be interesting
to know how he would answer the
following question
shortest descriptions in what language
well there you know but I do think
that's an answerable question I think
computer scientists think about that
there's some universality you know
there's some you know in in the studies
of Kolmogorov complexity there's like
some wiggle room but not infinite wiggle
room and answering that question right
right right so that would be interesting
to dig into there's a there's a kind of
famous variant on the problem of
induction here too did Nelson Goodman
that involves like using weird
predicates to describe a pattern this is
the grew and leaned oh yeah problem
which you may have heard of which kind
of arises here because the kind of
example Goodman had in mind is very
simple like much simpler than the kind
max is thinking about yeah but if you
imagine that you go out into your garden
every day and you look at your tomatoes
and you notice that the young ones the
unripe ones are green and the ripe ones
are red you can describe the pattern
you've observed in two different
vocabularies you can use the familiar
vocabulary of green and red or you could
use the kind of bets vocabulary where
you say something is I mean a change for
Goodman it was blue and green were the
things now it's gonna be red and green
right I say something is like reen if
it's green up until 2020 or red and it's
a
2020 and I say something is grad if it's
read up until 2020 or green thereafter
the clever move here is that green and
red are intruder findable with green and
grad right and so now we can ask like
what which is the right way to describe
this we might say well look a world in
which the colors flipped on that date
2020 would be a less simple world we
should believe our world is not simple
well it looks less simple if you
describe it using the green red
vocabulary yeah but using the green red
vocabulary it'll look simpler it's the
world in which no very young tomatoes
are mean and right tomatoes regret
always this seems to be a problem that
could in principle be overcome because
of the fact that these concepts do not
exist in isolation right yes there are
photons there is the universe sensory
and maybe there's not as much free play
of labels as we might imagine that's
right so you'd want a bike mat you'd
want to look at how things appear when
you're down at the level of like
fundamental physical details is there
still the same flexibility available I
think there's some flexibility there
like if there's Hamiltonian versus
Lagrangian mechanics right but but it's
not infinite okay okay
and just because we have to cover so
many centuries of knowledge in such
little time so Lewis sets out this idea
of possible worlds he supposes that
they're real sorry we do we have on the
table like the best argument that we
should think of them as real I can give
you what I think is the best argument
but it really demands a crucial premise
which is that an account of possibility
and necessity that doesn't analyze those
terms in other terms that have no modal
character to them is distinctively
inferior to an account that does analyze
them in non-modal terms and i don't know
how to argue for that premise lewis in
this famous work called on the plurality
of worlds employs that premise very
cleverly and i indicated some of the
ways i guess I didn't give him proper
credit but it was from reading that book
that I were in
this point about the best complete
stories that to make that account of
possible worlds work you really do need
a modal notion the notion of consistency
down at rock-bottom don't analyze away
and for Lewis that was an incredibly
serious cost now what I again don't know
how to make plausible as why that was a
serious cost and it may be that at heart
there was like this deep human
sympathies he had he was a human about
laws of nature but it may be that that
ran much deeper that an ocean an
unanalyzed notion of possibility or
necessity is just Anathem I like there's
something just found ly mysterious about
that I'm certain these personally
skeptical out the reality of other
possible worlds but I think I could
sympathize with the feeling that it
would make life easier life if we yeah I
have to keep using these in our talk
just believing in them ya know just it
takes a burden off our shoulders right
that's right and it is true that
philosophers often talk the way Lewis
would recommend that they talk ya
routinely say things like well there is
a possible world in which and we don't
we're not careful about this we don't
say there is a consistent story about
the world according to which we just say
no there's this thing that's right you
know clusters of all people are supposed
to be careful something good night so I
think this is bringing us back to what
it means to be the cause of something
because when you know when we say I got
sick because I had bad sushi we're
comparing the world we live in to
another possible world in which I didn't
have sushi right yeah right right it's
not just any possible world cuz you know
here's a possible world in which you
didn't have bad sushi you had bad
chicken wings instead it's totally good
right yeah so so that that's where all
the fun lies right it's like caesarian
yes how do we compare the hospital yes
yes there's been a lot of thought put
into this recently by philosophers and
non farmers alike and a little back
story there why are not philosophers
involved in this debate well there are a
lot of non Foster's who worry quite a
lot
about how we can draw conclusions about
what causes what from statistical data
on data yeah yeah and again this is an
area where I'm no expert on the history
but I'm pretty sure that statistics as a
field started out in the early 20th
century fairly hostile to the notion of
causation you can find I've actually
checked one like important work I think
it was Pearson now book length treatment
of statistics brutally in the 20th
century where there's a whole chapter on
why no ship causality should be banished
and good science well today of pearl who
is you know leading the counter attack
there yes certainly is very vocal about
the fact that statistics as a field has
does not take causation seriously just
put it that way right right right but
the early statisticians did have a point
in the sense that it's if you compare
our ordinary way of talking about cause
and effect to the ways of talking that
they were recommending in terms of
precisely definable notions of
correlation it looks like with respect
to scientific rigor it's no contest no
the notions of correlation there's so
much more rigorous you know it again but
it's it's reminiscent of the human
versus anti give me an argument right if
you know what all the correlations are
what yes yeah yeah things yes absolutely
absolutely and so that's a that's it sir
deep foundational question I think and I
think that if I had to say what the
prevailing view of that question is
among people like pearl who are fans of
causal talk it's that you get the kind
of knowledge you need to help you decide
how to intervene because when we're
deciding how to which by the way is
another sort of hypothetical possible
world kind of display right like if I do
intervene if I don't right that's right
yeah in fact we probably should have
brought that up earlier because that
that's in a way the most sort of
immediately intuitive way in which we
and our encounter with the world are up
to our ears on hypotheticals we're
constantly thinking about what would
happen if I were to do this or to do
that or retrospectively who might think
like oh if only I had done that know and
someone like crow takes that kind of
talk
seriously and no right Lisa sure yeah
look what whatever a philosophical
stances are we do talk that way we kind
of have to yes right right right
and I suppose in a way I was getting
that at that without wild thought
experiment about the two theories yes no
because that evokes the same sort of
thought that like well there's a
structure to the possibilities that's
preset and when we're reasoning about
what to do we're sort of wondering what
that structure is like No
so for for for fans of what has come to
be called an interventionist approach to
causation has lots of different labels
the core thought that is that causal
relations are relations that at least in
principle are exploitable for purposes
of manipulation okay they so another way
to put it is our interest in causation
is an interest in facts about the world
that we can use to settle what would
happen if what would happen there kind
of do one thing or another and you can
easily think of examples where
manipulation is by humans is off the
table we might wonder what would have
happened to the dinosaurs if no asteroid
hit struck at a certain point and for
people who take this interventionist
approach I think you're supposed to see
that as a kind of natural extrapolation
of a kind of way of thinking about the
world that really has its home in human
agency and when when you say it that way
just seems so sweetly reasonable then
how can there so it isn't that just
right but what are the other possible
ways to think about causation I think
that that is an open question and and I
find myself in a rhetorically awkward
situation here because I think there's
severe limitations on the
interventionist approach which I can
explain but it would be much better for
my purposes if I could say oh and here's
a nice alternative right but it's
actually hard to think of an alternative
it's like string theory in quantum
gravity like you know it's it's the
leading candidate and many or the
multiverse is even better example and
explaining cosmological fine-tuning well
I had Leonard Susskind on the podcast
and he you know it's a fan of the
multiverse and how it explains why
various parameters and our observable
universe have he added the numbers that
they do and he gets a lot of pushback
for that and he says just tell me what
else it could be like I don't want it to
be this but I have a theory that
predicts it it seems to work I'm gonna
go again until you can do better yeah
which
which i think is a reasonable attitude
especially for a working scientist I
think you have to be careful though not
to throw too many babies out with the
bathwater
so just to indicate where where some of
the difficulties arise in the social
sciences we might want to attribute
effects to features of the world where
the it's not just that we can't
manipulate them it's not even clear what
we would have in mind by manipulating
them so know maybe your social class has
effects on downstream effects on the
kind of opportunities available to you
we think how do you manipulate someone
in social class directly like and it's
important to recognize that the
background idea here is that causal
relations are the kinds of relations
that would be manifested in an ideal
controlled experiment yeah exactly
so what would be a controlled experiment
in the possible world language that
corresponds to something like a minimal
change that's right that's right
in fact the cleanest change would be you
have a godlike power to swoop in on the
cosmos at some localized place in time
tweak it while holding everything else
at that time fixed and then see how
things evolve forward and in some sense
that's what pearl tries to formalize
yeah yes closed-loop calculus yeah yeah
yeah though he's a little quietest I
think about how how the what the
background is like here for me I come at
this against the background of all the
stuff we've been talking about about
laws of nature we're saying like well if
you've already got in place however you
think about them he me and or anti-human
things that you're gonna treat as laws
that that tell you how to extrapolate
forward from any given complete state of
the world then we can kind of get some
control over counterfactuals that
involve like localized changes to a
stand
no but pearl doesn't say much about that
he doesn't as I would put it this is a
place where I would want the
counterfactuals that he describes in his
council diagrams I would want them to be
analyzed in terms of something else yeah
and and that that made you knows maybe
that's just an aesthetic preference on
my
part where he's happy to treat that
notion really is a kind of primitive and
build a formal system around it okay but
he were giving us reasons to be
skeptical of intervention right so if
you think of like social features like
like classes one but here's one race you
might think that that what race you have
has effects on your prospects but that's
a little awkward if you're an
interventionist to try to answer the
question what would be a perfectly
controlled experiment yeah no in this
case or they're much more mundane
examples to their their everyday example
so so you're right now wearing a kind of
know a blue gray shirts here's a
question we could ask how would this
conversation have gone differently or be
going differently right now if your
shirt were some wild Hawaiian Prince
no maybe it wouldn't go to Menelaus tree
tonight for me what was that question
yeah right here's a way not to clarify
that question about about the influence
you're the color of your shirt may or
may not be having on the course of this
conversation right now at this moment we
should not clarify that question by
seeing it as the question how would this
conversation go from this point forward
if your shirt as a result of a localized
intervention were a Hawaiian prints like
a loud wine print rather than this nice
blue grey you know because the the
hypothetical situation we're imagining
here is one where you know as it were
God's woop sin makes a localized change
to the pattern on your shirt and then we
see how our conversation goes forward
from there here's how the conversation
would go understand and and once you
notice this this problem ramifies in the
social and psychological ropes is
actually a student of mine Alex Prescott
count she's now a philosophy professor
at Oxford who really pointed this out to
me at least quite clearly how widespread
this issue is now he imagines a case
where oh you know there's a
Joey is a student at a school and Joey
has is a child of a single parent and
gets teased a lot at school for being a
chow
of a single parent because his
classmates you're kind of jerks and Joey
is stressed out and you might you might
think it's a good question
how the teasing is interacting with the
fact that he's just got a single parent
in producing a stress and for an
interventionist the the natural way to
approach this question is to ask like a
bunch of hypotheticals like there's the
actual situation where the variable you
know the parent variable is set at one
and the teasing variable is set at on
and we're what we should do is contrast
that with hypothetical situations in
which those variables have the other
possible values yeah and and that works
okay for some settings of those
alternative variables we could
meaningfully ask how stressed out he
would be if he weren't teased but still
had just one parent or how stressed out
he would be if he had two parents and
Lauren's teased here's the weird one how
stressed out would he be if he had two
parents and were systematically teased
at school for having one okay and as
Alex points out he would be in some
Kafka and whatever like whatever our
answer to that question is it simply
does not seem to be illuminating the
causal question we were asking in the
first place seems like the wrong way to
think about it and it's kind of a
minimal change yeah that's right it's
the minimal change yeah and there are
other things too if we think about
protracted events like maybe Randolph
for example smoked heavily in his 20s
and he got cancer in his 50s and we're
curious about whether his decade-long
history of heavy smoking caused his
cancer notice we're not curious about
whether that puffs on that occasion
causes cancer yeah we're really feel
like in order to track the causal
relations were interested in we need to
zoom out to a larger longer time scale
so what would it be to intervene on that
history in a localized way that doesn't
introduce potentially confounding
variables like that's the crucial thing
so very roughly and perhaps unsatisfying
Lee the situation we seem to be in is
talk of causation whatever it means to
talk of it does involve a compare
of different possible worlds what is not
completely clear is how to do the
comparison which I think that's a very
good and it's bet it's interesting to me
especially because in science over and
over again we reach situations where
we're asking and caring about different
questions because of advances in
technology like quantum computing for
example now that we can do it but in
some sense this is an example where
maybe not within philosophy but in the
rest of the world we're asking this
philosophical question because of
advances in technology now that we're in
the big data era and we can see some
correlations the idea of pointing them
and and being a good inductor or
whatever seeing some pattern and
attaching some emergent reality to it is
becoming more important yeah I think
some social scientists who were fans of
this interventionist approach would
really emphasize this kind of point they
would say you know we're now in a
position to do causal investigation or
causal inquiry better and this
interventionist approach provides us the
right conceptual tool we now have the
ability to use that tool because we can
we can either do randomized controlled
trials or the like the best social
scientists are incredibly clever at
finding ways in which nature has done
that for us
yeah and that will give us insight in in
a kind of rigorous grounded way that we
didn't have before just by going and
talking to people or living with them
and so on but there there is no ongoing
kind of uncertainty and I think within
that field or even sort of outright
dispute about whether we're losing
something if we just sort of set aside
as kind of unscientific or under
interests those more quote/unquote
qualitative methods yeah they have
historically been very important but it
sounds like there's plenty room for
useful productive interaction between
philosophers and social scientists here
that's the hope all right that's always
a good lesson to end on so Ned Hall
thanks so much for being on the pond oh
you're welcome it's been a delay
[Music]
you
[Music]